[Musica]
[Applauso]
non so domande che non mettevo st sigla
ma mi ero dimenticato quanto fosse vi
capita a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
tornati dopo non so quanto tempo ma
veramente tanto comunque un saggio in
sicurezza praticamente ragazzi in
occasione dell'anniversario del video
che mi hanno messo un nuovo dlc non ci
sono due nuove operazioni che sono
queste degli occhi
bellissima e poi c'è questa qui dei
denti che però devo ancora sbloccarla
per prima devo fare quella degli occhi
cosa cosa ho cliccato già perfetto se
siamo già partiti io non ho cliccato
niente prova beh non importa perché no
che cazzo regala qualcuno qualcuno
aggredisce un po di occhi non lo so io
offro in poi non si sa mai cola poche un
brindisi regalerà c'è un cin cin con con
gli occhi proprio così allora sentire
alla salute si prova ci piano cioè ti
ubriachi subito la vediamo di fare le
cose per bene crisi chiedono gli occhi a
sto tizio si sta addormentando dalla
prima ti tolgo st mascherina magari
asilo ceylon pencil adoperati a pugnala
la zia ascolta un attimo lo faccio fare
per la tua salute credimi e cioè che
botto cioè lo sto prendendo a cazzotti
in faccia per romperli una mascherina
vabbé da letizia però ti svegli o ti
sveglio che no perché sono passa alle
maniere forti va bene joanna ragazzi
credo di averli staccato un occhio ma
non ne sono sicuro ci togliamo sta roba
dalla faccia grazie chiedete la messa ai
un'espressione veramente intelligente
pro fattelo dire ma che et ha messo sta
merda in faccia fa mica perfetto ma sono
anche tra nell'occhio a siringano perché
sembri molto sveglio
che bello che cazzo sto facendo la scusa
di assetto picchiato la guancia
mi spiegate come faccio a togliermi gli
occhi perché sa cos'è sto coso i soldi
sto facendo le sopracciglia ragazze che
cazzo di sto facendo le sopracciglia
forse devo privato agli arti queste e
poi ti si tolgono io ne ho staccato un
occhio regalo non so come meglio
staccato un occhio va bene ma è bene
così se tipo andassi col taglierino non
lo so ho cazzo ragazzi mi sa che ho
fatto un pò un casino togliamo questo
che forse non se allora io ti lascerai
anche così a perché 66 più bello è
difficilissimo togliere gli occhi cav h
mezz'ora velo chimica se perdo mi cazzo
cazzo ci ho messo 40 minuti no togliti
se gli occhi verdi e vivi lurido stronzo
baby cazzo ma no no no [ __ ] cielo che
abbiamo fatto un'operazione spettacolare
preciso al millimetro e questo vi muore
pure ma [ __ ]
io sta cosa delle sopracciglia non la
capirò mai ma va bene così che cosa
cazzo mi hai preso per un centro
estetico e ragazzi vi presento il mio
nuovo compagno di giochi è molto
simpatico mi dovete spiegare se ha
funzionato tirargli un ceffone dai cazzo
dai cazzo se ce l'ho fatta maledizione
ho messo mezz'ora per togliergli
altrimenti dopo prenderlo a schiaffi
finché non si toglievano fantasma mi è
partito un occhio prima cosa no no no no
no tu stai qua stai fermo cosa fai
perché sta roba fluttua ma siamo nello
spazio si sa come mai barattoli non
hanno la gravità fantastico non ho
capito perché ma non importa tutto gli
analisti occhi prima che ci mettiamo
mezz'ora a bra è così che si cucina
maledizione dove cazzo sta morendo
veloce veloce la siringa bbb beve ok è
stabile o capi mi sa che devo prendere
perché diavolo sta bene si sta muovendo
da sola ne sa niente non c'è non si può
fare cazzo cosa lega
no no cosa è successo di morire ma le
devi morire
distacco a morsi piuttosto che li nervi
la miste minchia di occhi cagare mori
tua madre e tuo zio tutta la famiglia
propria non sorso tenendo un occhio in
mano ma lo sto anche facendo levitare
con la magia è bellissimo fra la sentite
posso posso metto l'occhio eccolo
perfetto sono anche azzurri into andata
di culo da adesso in avanti apro un
centro estetico dove impianto occhi c'è
se volete passare io metto chi è
siamo contenti tutti forse sì
yo yo creare versione bionda occhi
azzurri
io e basta mai sono diventato un dottore
provetto quindi non ce n'è bisogno gran
grati gradiente applausi
grazie grazie ha fatto sclerare come
pochi vi prego fatemi vedere questa
pianto lo jia dentale che bello che
senza questa cosa fa teme la parola io
non so sinceramente non so che cosa si
sono inventati tese quello di prima era
difficile questo che cos'è oddio prima
di tutto ragazzi togliamo la maschera
perché se no non si può far a giacche
non si toglie ogni tipo di da [ __ ]
mila mascheri se s'è tolto ragazzi si
sta togliendo sta ammazzando però
soltanto tolto una chiazza di mascherina
sta già morendo fantastico i brutti i
denti che c'hai zio mio dio cioè sei
messo malissimo proprio a chi è bello
che tipo ii infilzo al mento e si vede
nella bocca e bellissima sta cosa
siccome ragazzi sono incerto si su come
si tolgano i denti vado vado
direttamente così perché sennò le
maniere forti risolvono tutto ecco
perfetto che devo cambiare i tre denti
ma gli sta togliendo 55 ce spiegatemi
bravo bello da zio quanto sei bella
togliendo tutto tranne quello che devo
ok s'è tolto sta ingoiando tipo tutti i
denti però va bene mi spiegate ragazzi
come faccio a prendere dei denti che non
riesco a prendere da anche un martello
con la mano come faccio a prendere dei
denti con le dita troppo il ciccione non
ce la faccio
sì sì ci ho fatto regalo preso
non so come ho fatto non ho idea
sì bravo madonna che bei denti sto
facendo ragazzi è come nuovo sto tizio
c'è un sorriso smagliante posto neanche
toccando sta lievitando l'attrezzo
massimetti di mangiarti denti ma ho
capito che non ci vede più dalla fame
però esistono le fiesta non è nervoso no
cosa se ho vinto ho vinto
non so che cosa cazzo fatto ma ho vinto
e va bene così e che sorriso ragazzi
sono più che soddisfatto dell'operazione
noda è veramente è stato fantastico
quanto sono belli miei pazienti dopo che
gli accurati di un accordo ragazzi
siccome sto morendo tipo di caldo costo
camicia da da un'ora e mezza e che
possono concludere qui vedo comunque
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto cobas
editore sotto un commento mi piace anche
la presa di facebook che comunichino tra
la descrizione pene severe cities
meccanici vediamolo costruito e da
ragazzi